("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
Hey guys, so, this is
our new feature for Mondays
as we continue to hack.
Last week, we tried
to do the week in review.
This week, what we're doing,
and, by the way, this
is just because I'm trying
to really think about
the work/life balance thing,
obviously, Biz Dev Sunday,
it's a lot of
fun to be on Sunday,
so I will film that in
my workout on Saturday,
but Sundays I'm not
gonna probably film,
but instead what
DRock and I and team Babin
are gonna do, is we're gonna
focus on putting a full clip
from the week that we
didn't show in its entirety,
where I set it up as well here.
And so, this week's
clip was an interview I did,
which was actually
about workspaces, right?
Like, Foosball tables
and like, snacks,
show the snacks, DRock.
Snacks, and all that stuff,
all the cool stuff
Facebook and Google does.
Like, what are
these couches and chairs
and all these things mean to
the production of a company?
I had a pretty
interesting take on it.
Here it is.
I think they feel at home
because I feel
like I'm a parent.
And I think all my actions,
between the room they live in,
and the psychology I deploy,
the listening and the talking,
I think people only feel at home
when the parents
make it feel at home,
and I think that's
the job of every CEO.
Yes, businesses can
start actually giving a fuck
about people instead of
how much money they make,
because a funny thing happens
when you give a
fuck about people.
You end up making more money.
I mean, I don't
think it's unfortunate,
those companies should
then make what is appropriate,
and all the people
that work there,
this is, you know,
most places in the world
have some level of freedom.
They're more than welcome
to start their own company
or work somewhere else.
This whole narrative of
these businesses are shit,
yes, do I want businesses
to care about people more?
Yes, it feels nice
and it feels right,
and it's a
legacy I want to leave,
and I think that it'll
actually make them more money,
but the employees aren't being,
this is not slavery, right?
Everybody has to be accountable.
This isn't just
the man is fucked up
or the business is fucked up.
The employee's fucked up if
they're in the shit situation.
Instead of going home at five
o'clock and drinking beer
and complaining, go on fucking
job listings, interviews,
networks, find a
fucking different job.
You know, to be very frank, I,
you know, the Foosball tables,
which I think we have a
hockey thing 'cause I like that.
The good cafeteria,
the free granola,
I just think that's horse shit.
Those are tactics
that bullshit companies do
to try to make people,
the people are
inspired and feeling good
because they feel safe,
and they feel
like they can grow.
They feel like safe and
they feel like they can grow.
That's the shit that matters,
not fucking free
Cheerios on fucking Tuesday.
Or, like, inspiration,
I like putting up signs
and I do that shit,
but I don't think people
Vayner are
happy and killing it
because I have a picture of me
saying your funeral matters.
That's up there
because I like that.
You know, like, not because
that's there as a tactic.
It's all religion.
They have to feel safe
and they have to feel like
they can grow, and that's it.
Everything else, you're
not gonna trick people
by having 24 hour
massages in a fucking room.
You know what I mean?
Band-aids,
everybody's got Band-aids,
nobody gives a fuck
about your hardwood floor,
or the soda fountain machine.
They're nice, and we
have them, but I'm not the one
who's ever making that happen.
That's other people
in my company
that decide those things.
I have no interest
in Band-aids.
Shit works
because I give a fuck.
I mean, look bro,
I'm gonna give you
the shittiest interview
ever, I can feel, right?
'Cause it's gonna
be the same stuff.
Like, good good good,
because every
other of your interviews
is gonna give
you bullshit answers.
Here's the real answer:
Speak to people,
talk to them, care about them.
Your first ten employees are
the foundation of your company.
They're the steel beams and
the concrete at the bottom
of your building
that nobody will ever see.
They need to be into you and
you need to be into them.
And the only way you get
to that is speak the truth,
communication, the truth,
communication.
I think the whole, yeah, no
no, no, no, no, no, it's okay,
the ultimate, for me,
the Holy Grail of design
and office space and
things of that nature,
is that it is not a
tactic to cover up the issues
of the company, got it?
I don't want it to be
a pretty dress, you know,
and you're out of
shape underneath, right?
It needs to speak to the truth,
which is, if it's fancy, great.
You like fancy things, good.
I mean, I'm not
against anything.
Everybody has to do them.
But it can't be a front.
It can't be charming at the
bar and a shithead boyfriend,
you know what I mean?
Good, I'm glad it does.
(laughs)
Awesome, man, good luck.
My pleasure.
Take care.
Hey guys, one of
the things I realized
that I'm not doing enough of,
and thank you, DRock,
is subscribe to the vlog,
to subscribe to
the YouTube channel.
Please do that.
And, also, would love
to get your favorite clip
of this week's DailyVees.
Please put it down below.
This is for the hardcore fans.
Please clip it.
Put the episode number
and the timeframe in it.
We've got some
surprises for you.
("Love Hate" by Fiifi Jr.)